this is the ocho de agua
the eye of water 350 liters of fresh
cool water
bubble up out of the spring every second
it's at the heart of a large water park
much loved by locals
it's in belen a suburb of costa rica's
capital san jose
a million people live in and around the
city
and water pours forth from springs
across the area
people are used to having a lot of water
so they use it for things that aren't
really necessary
the challenge we face is to teach them
that we actually need to protect and
conserve water
and we should only use it when we really
have to
say jimenez espinosa works for the
berlin municipality
on its water conservation program
as part of that the city seeks to buy up
land in private ownership
where there are springs in order to
create conservation areas
this plot is the first the city has
bought
the official list comprises 30 springs
in belen
but there are probably many more
escalgunas sometimes people just don't
tell us if they have a spring on their
property
or they say yes there's a little water
in my garden but not much
and when we go and investigate it turns
out it's a real spring
and we need to secure the land
real estate in berlin is expensive so
this purchasing project is two
it's being financed by means of a levy
on water that residents have to pay
costa rica is very serious about water
access to drinking water has recently
been written into the constitution as a
basic right
and that covers the conservation of
springs
ninety-five percent of the population do
have access to clean drinking water
still the government is keen to do even
better
berlin is also upgrading its waste
management so the trash doesn't
contaminate the soil ground water or
springs at this facility
workers are looking for materials that
can be recycled
this is also part of the program to
protect water resources and the
environment
this project is about ensuring that
stuff doesn't end up here at the dump
but gets recycled
and we don't use more and more water to
manufacture more and more goods
if lots of products can't be recycled
then we should stop using more resources
to make them also a social aspect to the
recycling project
the people who sort the trash have each
faced major problems in their lives
here they have the opportunity to make a
living they work on their own account
selling whatever they find to recycling
companies
there are seven of us at the moment
living from this project
with the money we make we first cover
our costs
and then divide up what's left among
ourselves
see susan astorga had just split up with
her partner when she started working
here several years ago
suddenly the homemaker was a single
mother with two boys to feed
sorting trash was meant to be just a
stop gap
i've developed skills i never knew i had
i like to manage the project and assume
responsibility for others
i've really come to love the project
belen residents are expected to sort
their trash into various categories
but many don't trash collection here is
on thursdays
but the workers from the sanitation
department won't take stuff deposited on
the roadside
unless it's properly sorted
another project only implemented on a
few streets so far
has inspectors review trash waiting for
collection by the roadside
jorge naranjo is one of them the sacks
may only contain things that can be
recycled
here we have a problem
this is just garbage it can't be
recycled
i'll take a photo and i'll send it to
the municipality
el centro de informacion de la
municipality
such photos help the sanitation
department identify the most common
mistakes residents make
the biggest problem has proved to be
organic waste
so 300 households have been given a
composter
tatiana navarro porras is one of the
lucky ones
she's been composting diligently for six
months now
you have to put leaves on top a layer of
moist waste then a layer of leaves
we can look after our planet we just
have to want to
tatiana navarro porras lost her job in a
hotel when the pandemic hit
now the family has only one breadwinner
her husband
[Music]
they've long been concerned about the
environment and use water
sparingly
a few days ago we got a letter from the
municipality congratulating us because
our water consumption is so low
the congratulations were printed on our
annual statement congratulations for
doing such a good job
that praise is also a way for the city
to encourage people to continue to use
water wisely
the springs here yield plenty of fresh
water and that's not about to change
nonetheless costa rica is working to
improve the management and
conservation of its water resources
our bodies are to a large extent made up
of water
we need food and water to live water is
a source of life
you